wanna go cause we can go right now dog
what's going on right man what the hell
are you doing man
what what what what trying to bob and
weave it what
your bitch-ass punk-ass [ __ ]
let's go come on man come on no no don't
look at your boys look at me man
don't look at you boy ow
[Music]
hey what's wrong man i was having a
nightmare
oh again
but you want to talk about it i miss
mommy
hey i know i know it's hey me too
me too pal
come here man it's all right hey it's
okay
it's gonna be okay
i just don't want anything ever happened
to you happened to me
hey come on man ain't nothing ever going
to happen to me
really yeah
that's what i said so yes that i'm
nothing never going to happen to me you
ain't never gonna have to worry about
nothing happen to me
but what if what if you got hit by a car
or something
that's impossible because i will never
die
so i can't die
no matter what you can't die but i
thought
all human beings died
that's true that's true that's science
so that's true but
i am lucky cause i'm i'm not
a human you are not
i never told you about this no
you know i'll just let it out i'm from a
planet called
thelonious the thing is it was
being destroyed all right that's what
happened my
was i was sent down here in in a capsule
to earth by my parents oh like superman
superman yep that is what
it is exactly like except oh here's the
thing about my version
only one superpower immortality oh
yeah so i'm tired daddy's tired
can you let's go to sleep okay
but i'm not gonna live forever right
because because i'm only half alien
oh no so i'm going to die
you you you write about yourself
ex but
here it is this one slit my mind
you can build with me
immortality the machine to give you what
i got
from the remnants of my spacecraft so
yeah
wow you're gonna be immortal you're
gonna be
immortal daddy when are we gonna get the
remnants
tomorrow tomorrow
gonna get them tomorrow during work
hey you got anything that looks like
parts of a crash spaceship
did mom mm-hmm right this way
um hi uh are you earl peel
who the hell want to know
i think i'm your son jordan peel
oh okay i see
come on you're here for a minute close
the door on the way in all right all
right man go ahead and have a secret i'm
gonna explain something to you okay
[Applause]
i had your dad all right i'm sorry to
disappoint you but that's the situation
brother
are you you see what's happening
we're doing the same thing i i always do
this i always scratch the back of my
neck like this whenever i'm in an
uncomfortable situation
scratch my neck man everybody scratch
their neck
i breathe in and out too man uh now
everybody my kid
okay look at this that's a picture of me
when i was a baby
that's my father
that ain't me man look look look man
look at that dude's afro look
i got this going on man my hair is gray
he got black hair i mean
he handsome as hell but i ain't nobody's
daddy
i'm sorry i just been looking for him
everywhere
yeah yeah sure you're here it's just i
got my own tv show now
i don't know i just i know that wherever
he is
he he would be proud you got your own tv
show huh yeah
yeah yeah i'm producing and acting
um oh you oh you producing and acting
right
okay yeah that's that's my boy
look at that man we doing the same thing
what is that
holy sh that's jeans right there man
cause you can't do that
unless you're sharing mad genes with
somebody it's got to be in your dnas
oh you're my son
my baby boy thanks for your time you
come back oh man i missed you so much
now man
stop get off get off get up
oh hey
when i first came to your door you
wouldn't even acknowledge
okay okay you know what when i first
came in here stop that
when i first came in here you wouldn't
even acknowledge that i could possibly
be your son
but now only after i tell you that i
have my own show on comedy central
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa comedy central
get the [ __ ] out of my house
i'm just gonna sit down and relax
hey watch where the [ __ ] you going oh my
gosh i'm so sorry
oh i didn't see you had a baby there man
i'm sorry i ain't trying to fight nobody
with a baby
yeah hell yeah you won't
lucky [ __ ] huh well you're lucky
i'm carrying this baby
somewhere that look man you need to move
on all right i already told you
i'm not gonna fight you huh that's what
i thought punk
wanna go cause we can go right now doc
what's going on right man what the hell
are you doing man
what what what what trying to bob and
weave it what
you bitch-ass punk-ass [ __ ]
let's go come on man
come on don't look at your boys look at
me man don't look at you boy
ow oh okay you think you hard
all right but you know what i'm gonna
show you what time it is right now okay
slap me i'm right how about this huh now
what you're gonna do huh
now it's gonna do you ready cause they
can do it right now cause i can take you
out man
okay oh it's on now that's yup
you did you did
excuse me i need this
this what the what now man
what now let's go you know what
it's not even worth it man
that's what i thought so keep walking oh
okay that's vomit that is vomit
oh dear it turns out it wasn't a ghost
at
all it was my little sister hiding in
the basement
making the noises the whole time
oh shoot i forgot his juice boxes oh
i will be right back you'll be all right
with zach i think so okay
so zachary
you know i'm gonna be marrying your
mother and uh i'm gonna be moving in
soon and i just
i'm so excited to spend more time with
you
you know i know
that you had a hard time with your
father and
that it spanked you and you know
i just want you to know that's not gonna
happen with me
okay and i promise i will never
spank you oh
okay that's
okay um
i know why you did that but
i will never spank you because i know
that you still oh that's
uh i don't know that there's anything i
did to deserve that
oh hey this
[Laughter]
you okay
i'm gonna be real with you you can't go
hitting people
all right oh oh oh i ain't coming back
for that fourth one
all right so we done we got that out of
our system cause i know
that this this isn't you
oh i told you you want that
oh oh come on
i'm the good guy i'm i'm the good guy
man
look i'm never gonna spank you
i'm not gonna be like your father
i'm gonna be your friend
you need to respect me you understand
you little [ __ ]
i will respect you charles
if you play your role now listen up
i'm a bad bad boy charles
i don't need a [ __ ] friend
so go ahead marry my mommy move in
[ __ ] her as hard as you want just leave
me
the [ __ ] alone you do that
11 years from now i'll be out of the
house
and we won't have any problems
you don't and i
will break you
okay charles
[Applause]
how are we doing i love him
hello everyone i'm joseph carmichael
otis is
was my father but we are not here today
to mourn his death but to celebrate his
life
we knew otis as a teacher a community
leader
a role model a husband and a father
now i thought it would be nice to share
something about him
you all may not have known when my
father was younger
he was an actor in hollywood going
through my dad's things
i found this reel of his work as an
actor
i haven't seen it yet but i thought it
would be fun to watch
here with all of you today
where are my pies rebels
where are the pies i put on my
windowsill
why i don't know missy brother
why would anyone want to steal one of
your delicious blueberry pie
hey see to it you shine those shoes up
nice boy
yes sir you best be believing i will
i'll shine your shoes blacker than my
mama's booty
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
in 1964 my father
marched with martin luther king jr and
herrera belafonte
along with other renowned civil rights
leaders
oh